[Music]  for centuries one story has touched the  lives of people across the world this  holiday season you're invited to  discover the story of the first  Christmas from an entirely new  perspective I expected a left turn to  deserts ago that's it  I'll party through the rain from the  studio that brought you miracles from  heaven and Cloudy with a Chance of  Meatballs Steven Yeun keegan-michael key  Gina Rodriguez Zachary Levi Kelly  Clarkson Patricia Heaton Kristin  Chenoweth Tyler Perry Tracy Morgan and  Oprah Winfrey King Herod is up to  something you're in danger you need to  listen to what I'm about to say  extremely carefully  [Music]  do you want a belly rub  you jump out and create a distraction  [Music]  there's something seriously wrong with  those animals  [Music]  [Music]  you